很多人不理解导演思维与分镜的关系
总想着直接学分镜不学导演思维
但是这是先有机后有蛋的关系
这一期咱们着重的科普一下
咱们先通过一个案例去简单的感受一下
这段来自于我非常喜欢的电影《海地和爷爷》
这段是姑母带着海地进到团团里去找她爷爷时候的状态
首先是一个环境的大全景
持续的时间比较长
然后到人物的一个小全景
再然后警别切近
我们看清了人物的反应和状态
再然后从一个小全景切到一个大全景
再然后人物有对话有情绪
但是没有强化人物的情绪
它只发生在一个小的全景里面
好以上就是分镜的分析
每一镜你全都看到了
但是你学会了吗
很显然没有
而且是完全没有
为什么
因为这里面只有分镜的分法
没有思路的设计
好咱们看这里面有
一二三四五六七八八个镜头
但是发现没有
这八个镜头有一个共同的特点
就是它全都是一个外部的视角
而且是外部的观察视角
区别旨在于景别的所放
这个视角是什么意思
就是这里着重介绍村子的环境
观众看到了外部的环境
也看到了每个人的情绪
但是导演并没有在这个时候
选择让情绪激化
也没有进入任何一个人的立场与视野
换句话说
整个场景到现在
它属于是一个平铺直竖的推进
你看
这个就是导演目的
这个就是导演思维
因为这个思维
所以形成了这样的分镜
然后刚才的景别与视角
就是服务于导演思维的视觉工具
好
咱们继续往后看
后面导演思维发生变化
工具发生变化
呈现方式分镜逻辑
同样发生了变化
好
我们看
首先还是环境的介绍
算是一个场景的定位镜头
但是这一段核心变了
它变成了海地个人的刻画
首先你看这
进入海地的视野
然后就是海地的反应
他做出一个决定
然后是他们的位置关系
再然后就是海地的个人表演时间
好
注意看这
海地脱衣服时候的表达
它是一个精致的刻画
这里面有两个特点
第一个
它是非常具有动态性的
第二个
它全都是特写的描述
这是脱衣服的最后一镜
动态性达到了最强
为什么
因为情绪最强烈呀
然后海地像一把剑一样射出去
再然后就是一个动态的跟随
再然后进入海地的视野
好
这段它的分型设计包含了两部分
一部分是人物的主观镜头的刻画与反应
另外一部分就是人物的动作刻画
通过动作刻画去呈现出人物的状态
以及人物作为一个小孩子的天真与活泼
你看这里面核心基础是主观镜头的使用
以及通过长焦特写进行的一个动态性的刻画与表达
目的是在故事发生的过程中刻画人物形象
你看这里面有动静的结合
有景别与焦段的组合使用
同时还有第三人称以及第一人称视角的综合应用
然后就是导演目的以及导演工具的使用
生成了现在的分镜
其实通过上面一个案例的两个片段
我们就可以发现所谓的导演思维
它有两个大的部分
一部分是导演动机
就是导演希望这个场景表达什么
以及该如何去表达
另外一个就是导演对于导演工具的熟练使用
第二者是一个前提
刚才的这个描述它非常的笼统
但它也非常的纯粹
咱们通过短视频只能简单的感受那么一两下
但如果说要训练的话
其实是一个庞大的体系
在咱们的系统课程里有全面的阐述
以及从低到高完整的训练过程
在这呢我只能向您说清楚
导演思维和分镜它是先有鸡后有蛋的过程
学习导演思维的过程
其实就是分镜能力不断成长的过程
好咱们再看下面的这个案例
这个案例它非常的简单且实用
这是海地和爷爷一块去镇上
拿羊换粮食的路上
全程手法非常简单
它就是一个主观镜头的应用
以及人物不断反应的过程
但是这里面景别私似的锁在了人物的近景上
为什么
因为外面的人对爷爷非常的不怀好意
所以海地和爷爷非常的警觉
好看这从特写到环境
然后再到一个小玄境
你看这里面有新人物
但是他只是一个工具人
所以只在玄境里面一笔带过
然后就是牧师的出现
先有声音然后给到人物的反应
牧师在人物的反应时进入场景
同时是一个中进景
你看这个就是场景在全世界的过程中
做一个最为基础的分化
哪些人物是重要的
哪些是次要的
作者要把笔墨分配给谁
这个事对于老泡而言其实最为基础了
但是对于新手而言
往往分不清笔墨的深浅
以及笔墨的重点
好咱们再看最后的一杆利
此刻小海莉被她姑母给拐跑了
咱们看一下镜头是如何表达爷爷此时的状态的
好看这正面的跟镜头
然后是反面的跟镜头
第三镜给到人物的情绪特写
再然后给到一个大的环境
好以上就是分镜的设计
很简单对吧
但问题是为什么
你看此刻人物是特别焦虑的
但是前后的两个跟镜头
运动的速度不是很快
为什么
为了体现出爷爷的无力感
最后的这一镜为什么要这样呈现
依旧是体现出人物的无力感
而这个是另外的一种手法
叫做环境压制
然后回到爷爷的表情
让他继续往回走
这个时候如果是你
你的镜头设计又会是怎样的
这里导演思维继续发挥作用
就是用一个长镜头去记录爷爷的情绪
因为这个时候情绪是极度浓烈的
且无法消化
你看这杆里分镜非常简单
但是它的核心表达全都在导演思维上
首先导演思维决定了动态性的表达
这里动态性它是慢的
为了表现出爷爷的无可奈何
然后这里面还有构图的设计
用环境去压制人物
第三点就是长镜头的设计
什么时候选择用长镜头
其实是有时机有原因的
其实用分镜讲故事从来都不是难事
但是如何把分镜用对用准用的生动用的恰到好处
这个就是导演思维需要解决的事
总而言之这一期主题它并不复杂
但是作为新人和小白他并不知道
这个事一旦不知道往往就会走弯路
这弯路一旦走上去
可不是一时半会儿就能够绕出来
有的几个月
有的三五年
有的甚至更长
最后咱们回归到原点
学习分镜要先学导演思维
先学导演工具
然后再学叙事的方法
这个方法包括镜头的设计
包括剪辑思维的前置
然后再学导演套路
导演思维如何具体的呈现在每一个场景里面
这些都属于是导演思维的基础
然后再往上学抽象的就是情绪化的设计
以及节奏化的表达
同时还有观众的心理控制
这是一个由简路凡层层递进
由外延到内核的一个训练过程
很遗憾
他无法一上来就达到高潮
因为他得一步一步的走
因为他属于是创作思维的不断升级
而不是普通技术的重复应用
升级你的思维
而不是在那些普通的技术里面打转
这才是对的路
好了
就说这么多
有需要的就找我学系统课